origine et prend le volant à je ne
comprends toujours pas pourquoi je viens
pas avec toi et on le nomme déjà discuté
il y a un plan et c'est pas le moment de
tout changer bon d'accord
[Musique]
coucou ce que je t'ai dit tu dois
attendre dans le bateau où je pensais
que tu voulais pas de 5 d'actes m'en
serais voulu dire quoi d'autre il faut
qu'on trouve tu fais comme moi compris
tout va bien aller mignon me manque
[Musique]
dès qu'on appelait votre naissance à
toufflers et à toi ton père et moi avons
divorcé
chacun a pris un fils que d'élever de
son côté est évidemment j'ai eu la
mauvaise pioche
je ferai le bout
[Musique]
enfin je perds ma connaissance
heligoland témoins suis mal à l'aise
comment ça se passe pour toi au niveau
carrière
génial vous avez laissé le méchant le
plus recherché c'est que vous êtes virer
carrément génial ça dit gilles j'étais
fait venir pour reprendre l'entreprise
familiale
tu as la méchanceté dans le sang et
quelques années les c'est derrière moi
tout ça je comprends pas qu'on peut
servir ce truc
wola fâche bien méchant
pas mal du tout
[Musique]
alors vous avez c'est quoi aujourd'hui
accroche-toi
lien
howe
[Musique]
et ce à quoi bon les filles ça fait
longtemps qu'on attend
[Musique]
une fois j'en ai une et deux si douce
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir dutra
[Musique]
alors vous êtes des méchants maintenant